holy son of a [ __ ] haven't vlogged in
quite a minute in quite a minute quite a
bit but I'm here I'm back in our new
place super excited about it everything
is a freaking mess but I do not mind
because I love progress I love when
things
start changing and I could start living
my life again and it feels like I can
live my life again I'm in my closet
can't wait to start setting everything
up uh super excited for all of that I
want to show you guys backyard plans I
just want to show you guys so much and
everything but I'm gonna hold off on it
because there's a lot of content coming
your way when it comes to just Decor
backyard planning organizing everything
about moving
um everything about purchasing like we
got a whole slew of videos coming your
way uh where you're gonna get to learn a
lot of our mistakes and hopefully not
make them yourself and just different
not shortcuts but just different tips
and tricks and and all of that that
we've learned in this whole process and
I tell you mark mock mark my words
I'm not [ __ ] moving for at least five
years or if they go hey we'll give you
triple the prize for your house okay
I'll be real with you if they give me
the real [ __ ] if they give me a
really good price like at least minimum
triple what I paid for I'm moving
okay I don't know I really do like this
house you guys I really love this house
this house is
so perfect it's not too big not too
small
one story the energy feels amazing the
location is great the backyard's not too
big not too small we have a front
driveway
everything about this place feels so
homey It Centers me it relaxes me
it makes me feel at ease just knowing
that
you know I live in a cul-de-sac in a
gated community my son I can let him go
and play there's a lot of kids on the
street and I've seen kids play on the
street when was the last time you saw a
kid play on the street it's been a
freaking minute or at least I just don't
know where to go because I haven't seen
that honestly in a couple years and this
is I'm also talking about pre-covered
okay
like I just don't see it anymore I don't
know what's happening or what happened
or what area at least I was driving or
living by that I just didn't see kids
playing outdoors and it was really
breaking my heart so seeing that in our
community makes me so happy and the fact
that we live so close to friends it's
amazing and friends with kids because
Friends With Kids versus friends are two
different sets of friends and if you're
a parent you know what the hell I'm
talking about if you're not a parent
basically it's going out with friends
that drink and love to party versus
friends that don't drink and just like
to I don't know chill at a coffee shop
like it's just two different sets of
things and you just they can co-exist
but it's just a different vibe you know
what I'm saying
um today
is actually Halloween and I'm super
stoked to see taika halloweening it up
because we're gonna hang out with
Christina at uh Leia and Enzo and the
kids just love each other so much I'm
super excited to start all that but
this morning
we had a little incident okay
um taika ended up having a seizure he
woke up at five everything was fine
[Music]
um
we trained in the morning so he woke up
at five because the night before uh he
actually took a two hour nap which is
great anytime he wants to nap we let him
nap we let him nap for as long as he
wants to nap for like I don't care if
like you know he might stay awake
whatever he's such a good sleeper if
he's tired I let him go for it for as
long as he wants I don't wake him up
from his nap
um and something in me feels like
that might be part of I don't know why
he might be getting a seizure I don't
know I I just try to keep things as like
neutral and comfortable for him as
possible because I just don't know what
triggers these seizures just yet we've
done EEG scans we just completed a
24-hour EEG scan and basically that's
them looking into his like little brand
electricity is what I like to call it
and I like to explain it to him so that
he's very much aware of what's going on
every time we go to these doctor visits
or I tell him that he had a seizure like
I like tried to keep him in the know of
his health as much as possible and it's
worked wonders like he's not afraid of a
lot of things he understands why he
can't do certain things or why he has to
wear helmets
you know for other things when other
kids might not have to I'm very open
with my dude
um so yeah he took a long nap yesterday
fine so subsequently she ended up waking
up today at 5am when Norm normally he
wakes up like around six like he's an
early bird but today was
extra early fine whatever we needed to
wake up early anyways so we got some
training out of the way as we're
training he's just on his iPad you know
just doing the regular thing
usual morning nothing different here
so then it's around like 6 20 a.m and by
that time we start getting him ready he
starts having breakfast like we just get
back into the routine by 6 45 he takes a
seizure medicine
um nothing out of the ordinary there
okay so 6 45 rolls around we give him a
seizure medicine we really do try to
stick to that time because he has to
take it two times a day every day
haven't missed a dosage any of that so
I'm talking about 650 now
um he goes back to just wrapping up his
cereal he's eating like Wheat Thins or
something like not Wheat Thins those are
crackers but like Wheaties or some [ __ ]
like that he's eating that and then I
get super excited so I'm like oh my God
today's halloween and because we've been
moving and stuff like you know when you
move shit's a little bit Rocky you're
just you don't have your regular routine
like you're kind of just out of your
funk right so I'm like [ __ ] today's
halloween we didn't get to decorate like
it just doesn't feel very Halloweeny for
me I love celebrating all holidays
because that's just how I was raised and
that's how I grew up and
um so I just love to celebrate
so I'm like Hey Google play some
Halloween music and I'm like trying to
get into it and stuff and taika hasn't
put on his costume yet because again
he's eating his breakfast
so then I'm like oh my God Halloween
spirit this is so cool so I get really
excited and I start recording right
because I love whenever I get the chance
to I'm gonna try to share anything
anywhere this time around I was sharing
it on my Instagram stories I didn't
upload it
so you're getting the first year
so I'm going to show you whoops I'm just
taking random pictures on my phone so
I'm going to show you that Instagram
story that I downloaded didn't upload
didn't make live
because y'all this [ __ ] [ __ ] came out
of nowhere okay ready
so setting up the scene here
seven maybe like 650 okay wrapping up a
cereal everything's normal everything's
good I have his clothes and his costume
and everything laid out in the kitchen
ready to rock and roll remember we're
moving so shit's [ __ ] up all over the
place okay okay here we go
monkeys today is Halloween
you ready to dress up
playing the Halloween jams Doug is about
to get dressed in his little costume
zombie he's a zombie
did you catch that
that's the part
right there
when I was going he's a zombie he's a
zombie because he does real like he
should be an actor honestly like he
should side note I'm never putting him
and acting as a kid because his [ __ ]
Hollywood is creepy anyway
um
so that part he loves to act as a zombie
he'll be like and he drags his foot and
everything like to the T like he Nails
it like he should get a [ __ ] Oscar he
knows how to act really well so when he
was doing that I was like oh perfect
he's a zombie
but then when he didn't snap out of it I
was like oh [ __ ] he's having a seizure
and that's literally what happened as
soon as it cut through my phone on the
couch Tycho was he just started
stiffening up and he started having the
seizure and this is you guys the first
time
I ever saw him have the seizure he's had
several seizures already unfortunately
and it breaks my heart that I have to
show that but
he's had several seizures already it
seems like he's getting one every month
now which
breaks my heart for him because
luckily he doesn't remember or recall
any of it like at all
um but I mean okay I guess it just
breaks my heart because I just see it
and I'm like [ __ ]
um so you ended up having a seizure I I
set him on the couch and I'm just
talking to him the whole time I set him
on his side because that's what I was
directed to do and again I'm gonna
repeat it to you guys because I didn't
know anything about seizures prior to my
son having them but if you ever see
anyone kind of just staring off and they
just
are acting abnormally they might be
going through a seizure and they might
be having an episode every episode
doesn't look the same
um with taikas this time around I did
see him like you saw it too he zoned out
half of his face was like
was like smiling the other half was just
dead nothing behind the eyes and then
um he just started getting stiff so as
as soon as I saw him walking toward the
couch I just put him on the couch laid
him on the side so he doesn't choke
um drool started coming out he started
getting really really stiff my poor baby
and um I was just caressing him and
talking to him because there's really
nothing you can do at that point you
just have to let them go through it
um so I'm caressing him and I'm talking
to him and I'm just staying super
positive and I'm just like it's okay
baby Mama's here Mama's here Mama's here
and I'm talking to him
um and it lasts about
what feels like an eternity but if I
have to be realistic it was probably
like 30 minutes I mean
it was uh 30 seconds and that's
considered normal anything up to five
minutes is considered normal and not an
emergency can you [ __ ] imagine seeing
someone you love or just anyone
stiff drooling possibly shaking for five
minutes
I can't that I would just be like
[ __ ] [ __ ] someone's [ __ ] dying in
front of me that wasn't the case here it
did last about 30 seconds
again felt like an eternity talking to
him hugging him just letting him go
through it once I felt he got loosened
up I just started hugging him and then
he just like usually when I when I've
when he's had it at school
um where he tends to have it the most
because I mean it makes sense he spends
most of his time at school during the
week
um when I drive to the school by that
point he's already had it
um his speech hasn't returned yet so
we're talking about maybe
10-15 minutes after
and um
he's crying he's crying hysterically
because he just doesn't understand his
surroundings he can't communicate
anything he's probably in pain I mean I
don't know I'm just making this [ __ ] up
because whenever I asked haika he
doesn't remember anything
okay so this was him after
this was him after after the facts just
knocked out and that's what tends to
happen
he's just out sleeping
okay
literally all happened before school
okay I'm talking about now it's probably
seven o'clock
maybe like hugging him talking to him
just waiting for him to get his you know
to just feel like himself again because
it always feels like he just leaves like
it's just not taika anymore it's just
his brain just shuts down or something
it's
okay so then
the heck
so then this is me talking about
[Music]
he wakes up from that like 10 15 minute
nap and he's like zoing
nothing happened
we're like what the [ __ ]
this is him
he's just making noises being a funny
guy
funny monkey
[Applause]
what just happened
and it's like this guy has no idea
none
none
yeah it was like business as usual so
I'm just like
I was like
um okay uh
what do we do now so um I asked him hey
do you feel anything is anything hurting
like
um
you know are you okay and he goes yeah
Mom I'm really good
okay so then do we just take you to
school and
yeah he put on his costume he was super
excited didn't feel anything didn't
recall anything
I showed him the video that I showed you
and
he's like what
what is that what happened and I'm like
nothing at all dude let's just treat
this like a regular day so um yeah
took him to school so far so good
never dealt with this before don't even
know if that's the right thing to do
he's I asked him all the questions
everything checked off I don't want him
to miss any schools so we're like okay
let's go to school luckily he has a half
day today we're gonna pick him up
um because he has his Halloween parade
and I'll try to show that to you but and
there's going to be a lot of kids and I
just I don't know I was feeling
comfortable putting other kids other
people's kids in my Vlog without content
so I may or may not show that probably
won't show it but
um at least in the night time you'll get
to see his costume you'll get to um see
us all trick-or-treating and stuff so
I'm looking forward to that but
just had to share it man I'm like
I don't know I'm gonna try to talk about
seizures as much as [ __ ] possible
because it's
yeah a lot of people don't know about it
so don't ever freak out if someone has a
seizure just lay them down on their side
let them go through it look at a watch
look at your phone just look at what
time it is anything under five minutes
it's not considered an emergency just
let them go through it be positive talk
to them talk them through it nothing is
really you know alarming at that point
just hey let them have it when they come
back hey how you doing can I get you
anything do you need some water let them
come back
believe it at that
it's really that simple
um but yeah
that story time wasn't I didn't expect
for it to be this long I actually wanted
to talk about the house and just kind of
like talk about this a little bit but I
think it's really important that I share
a bunch of Caesar stuff with you guys so
that you feel very empowered and very
well equipped if you ever do encounter
that in your life so
yeah
we're doing the damn thing life tries to
[ __ ] throw a wrench in our system and
I'm like
foreign
T too hard because like I go and take so
much but I'm like so bring it I'm gonna
like [ __ ] bottom weave as much as I
can but [ __ ] let me just [ __ ] like
take a break yeah
okay anyway moving on
in other news look at that
can't wait to get my life together cause
everything's a [ __ ] mess I got some
temporary paper blinds here so if you're
moving and you don't want to put
newspaper and you want something a
little bit more presentable these do
costs
money unlike putting trash bags or um I
have different panels here or
um newspaper uh but again they do look
presentable you just stick it it just
has an adhesive and literally that's it
you're done so yeah
a little dining area with more mess
Tiger's little vending machine that he
did
I'll let him explain it to you at some
point
but
yeah
here we are fam
trying to just get our life together
liners I can't recommend this enough
line everything
cabinet because anything that will spill
will spill and ruin it and look you
can't even tell that it's there
just get clear ones
I've moved several times to know that
something is going to get ruined and it
just lasts longer like everything just
looks nicer this you can throw away it's
harder to and then more expensive
to redo these guys so especially
anything that has like water
you do want to get some liners
just so the water will land there and
not on the particle board or wood or
whatever type of material
your cabinets are made out of
a little Pantry that's actually a
[ __ ] human size because all our other
[ __ ] was just way too [ __ ] big this
is
decent like this is great this is more
than enough room look at that I don't
need that much food probably put just
[ __ ] there
and we got pop over here
pretend like he's working
I'm gonna stay back here because you
have a lot of tabs open my friend
whoa whoa I almost fell huh
oh
they just installed
our washer and dryer because our last
one when we sold our house
the people that wanted to buy it the
house were like uh can you also sell us
the wash and dryer we're like
zoing yeah take it we don't care so
Tyga doesn't even have a bed frame or a
bed that fits his bed frame so
we're a mess yo we are
a [ __ ] mess
but you know what I'm a mess
in my dream home
and that's
makes me so happy I'll be a mess all day
if I get to stay here for a long long
time and build a ton of memories I love
how like I have to like
I don't know I feel guilty leaving on
all these lights so as I'm Vlogging it's
like I can't even wait to turn off the
camera before I have to turn off the
lights I'm going I'm just wasting so
much power so I have to turn off the
lights
anyway
I hope you're having a better day than
me
all right y'all
it's almost night time
and uh
I have my Halloween costume on
but uh I didn't realize that it was only
like 50 of the costume so oh my God I
gotta trim my eyebrows
um so I had to just dig something up in
my closet because as you guys know a lot
of my clothes are
in a box
here's my costume
I'm supposed to be burning is it
supposed to be blue
I did my best deal
Papa
he's not here let me Wake Tech up
I've been happy this whole time
monkey
Halloween time
do I look cool
[Laughter]
hey do I look cool
hello does Mama look funny
oh boys
you ready to get dressed go see Enzo and
Leia
[Applause]
good morning
gummy okay I'll be waiting for you in
the living room okay
take your time
well this is uh
our normal occurrence for taika I
suppose because he's seen it all Papa
come here
come here
[ __ ] Brandon Huff you big cutie
[ __ ] your outfit are you gonna get ready
or what yeah I'm gonna get ready right
now let's go
do you want to do the do you want to do
the nasty
because you've had the old bull night
with the young cat hey
so we're at Ed and Christina's I'm not
gonna show what they're wearing yet
because I have to show you what my
brother's wearing
and now they want the young calf you
know what you know about books and hoes
from my chest cubes
okay and look at this cute ass family
we got a storm we got Thor we got taika
in a creeper
we got
um Spiderman and we got Wonder Woman
you guys look so cute especially you
dude you look hot Ram
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what are you doing
[Applause]
okay so this is hilarious because we're
about to grab dinner and literally no
one around us except us is dressed look
at all this regular clothes
everywhere
I'm like watching you driving your car
and I'm like what such a weird oh you
can see my little curly hair
oh my God we look awesome damn put that
badonkadonk girlfriend
yeah no that's your butt
hey dude
oh cool you can't see
it's so funny this is the best I love
this so much
no I just like what we look like we're
literally gonna walk in I don't want to
stress
oh my God
oh my God
look at that
there we go
treat it
what let me see
okay
there he is
such a big boy he's gonna go
trick-or-treating by himself well with
Leon Enzo I think that they went
together oh and then Theo and TR with
them
he still has muscles so we're good
Theo Thor
let me see right here right here what
did you get dude did you say oh this is
this way this way
yeah yeah let's go
oh he has candy
say thank you come on duty
monkey are you gonna go in this house
it's so cool what do you mean
you think it's cool you want me to go
with you you're not scared
no don't push anything okay go look at
that
it's pretend it's pretend
oh I don't know he's fighting oh there's
some candy that get a little bit okay so
everyone can share yeah
he looks so silly don't flip that out
the witch trying to fight him yeah it's
feisty oh yeah I was doing this
[Music]
that's cool
what do you see what do you see
Peter that's pretty bad yeah that's
pretty bad okay let's see what Theo that
was a zombie yeah
did we go in there
let's go let's go let's go
[Applause]
run run
yeah
oh my gosh take whatever you want
Oh no you're running fast
oh my God
look at that oh look at that oh wow look
at the purple and orange down here whoa
wow okay careful car car car car
oh we forgot to bring flashlights oh
yeah
all right bro this is my shot come on
dude come on come on yeah this is cool
wow look at her dress is so pretty
good job happy Halloween thank you
come on baby
I was waiting for a group oh good job
man good job good observation dad you
okay oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's so cool thank you
hey
get it take it get it take it get it get
it get it shake your booty shake your
booty get it baby get it baby
he got it from his mama with a fat
little booty hey
hey oh no too real
[Music]
look at this
this is so cool
there is but don't go inside look at
this
whoa
this is crazy oh sorry bro
[Music]
this is so cool
wow
[Applause]
wow
is this the exit
wait wait wait
[Applause]
whoa
wow wow this is so cool
go this way
I'll go say hi to that look go say hi to
that
he moved
wow
look at that chicken and
it's so cool
you guys look so good
we are back home
taika obviously already ate like four
pieces of candy holy crap I need to get
my hair dyed anyway sorry
um and now Tech is about to have his
last
bottle milk
and Papa's reading
the story for him sharpen their claws
stretchy and yawning with the great big
Jaws is that a spider look at these Jaws
why is there spider on your head don't
you dare move it
don't you dare let's put right there
watch what happens
fire hey
you want it there yeah you put it there
on purpose
he's so smart oh okay
oh no there's a there's a soccer ball
let me get rid of that no no what
okay okay
say goodnight monkey
s
need I say more
good night see you tomorrow